it was New York City in the 1960s and
the city was lit up with color and life
24 hours a day from The Madman of the
Madison Avenue advertising companies
with their crisp pressed suits slick
haircuts and even Slicker salesmanship
to the Revolutionary art and culture of
Greenwich Village it was the place to be
from dusk until dawn then all throughout
the day the streets were positively
flooded with people on their way to work
headed out for a night on the town or
looking to get into some trouble it
wasn't likely that you would notice one
man keeping to himself his hands in his
pockets the brim of his hat pulled low
over his forehead and casting a shadow
over his eyes unless of course you were
looking for him you see this particular
man had caught the attention of a
particularly unsavory group of fellows
the demaro crime family was not the sort
of group you wanted to get on the bad
side of especially the family's eldest
son Mario dimoro and unfortunately for
this quiet man in the slate gray suit
caving his head down he had found
himself smack dab in the middle of
Mario's bad side he hadn't done anything
wrong really he'd been walking by a
bakery a few days prior when he bumped
into a little old lady by mistake he
didn't mean to bump her he didn't mean
to make her stumble and he certainly
didn't intend to make her drop the
birthday cake she was holding but it all
happened just the same the cake box fell
to the ground the cardboard crumpled and
suddenly there was Vanilla sponge and
buttercream frosting splattered all over
the filthy City sidewalk the strange man
helped the little old lady back up to
her feet and apologized for the trouble
as she cried that her son's 30th
birthday was ruined he wants to adjust
her hat and run away and felt a Pang of
regret but soon forgot all about the
cake the lady the birthday Mario didn't
his friends called him Mario birthday
boy demaro for a reason all year he
looked forward to to one thing his
favorite cake from his favorite Bakery
delivered to him by his favorite person
his mother when Mrs dimaro described the
stranger who had caused her to drop the
cake Mario decided that this disrespect
to him to his mother to his entire
family would not go unpunished he sent
out a group of his favorite lackeys
Bobby the weasel passarella Vernon two
knife galetti and Ben the mammoth
Santoni they tracked the man down
figured out his usual haunts his
schedule the streets he walked down
every day and reported back Mario gave
the order it was time to make their move
and so on that ordinary day as that nice
neat polite man walked down the street
his cake mistake far from his mind Mario
and the boys watch from the Shadows
ordinarily Mario wouldn't involve
himself directly in this kind of nasty
business he would send others to do his
dirty work but this was was personal and
he wanted to be there to see the look on
this disrespectful stranger's face as he
learned his lesson the men trailed him
all day waiting until it was dark until
the man was alone then and only then
they would strike curiously the man
never did much of anything other than
walk around the city avoiding others if
someone spoke to him asked him for
directions he would answer them
courteously but then he would continue
on his way once he stopped at a
restaurant for a steak and a glass of
water but he seemed to have no job no
family no friends or really much of a
life at all though the others were
perplexed Mario was delighted there was
no one to miss this man once he was gone
this would be even easier than he had
expected as the streets grew darker and
the night deepened the Mobsters prepared
to execute their attack armed with
knives guns piano wire and all their
trusty Usual Suspects they were poised
for the perfect moment and that perfect
moment had a arrived the strange man
turned down an alley and the group
followed him into the Shadows they were
just about to Corner him when the man
turned around and faced them excuse me
Gentlemen The Man spoke in a clipped
voice refined but cold with an accident
none of them could quite place would you
care to explain why you've been
following me all day it's becoming a bit
unsettling the group froze shocked what
kind of game was this guy playing listen
here Wise Guy Vernon said holding one of
his signature two knives in each hand we
don't take kindly the folks with Bad
Manners we thought we'd give you a good
old-fashioned etiquette lesson have we
met this strange man asked perplexed no
but we're about to become well
acquainted Vernon took a step forward
the blades glinting menacingly in The
Limited light there was nothing behind
his Target but a closed off Alleyway
nowhere to run I don't think you want to
do that the man held his hands up in a
gesture of Peace please it would be a
terrible idea Vernon laughed
hello to this clown Ben Shrugged his
massive shoulders and cracked his
knuckles Bobby wound the sharp piano
wire around his fists ready to wrap it
around the stranger's neck enough Small
Talk got him Vernon Mario called out
stepping forward to get a better look at
his intended victim I've had just about
enough of this at his boss's word Vernon
rushed at the stranger stabbing him in
the stomach suddenly he cried out one of
his knives falling to the ground with a
clatter he grabbed at his own abdomen
stumbling back as blood poured between
his fingers he got me with what called
Ben I tried to warn you the stranger's
side almost sounding disappointed that
no one had listened to him forget it
I'll handle this Bobby grabbed a hold of
the stranger pulling the piano wire
tight across his throat no sooner had
the wire tightened across the man's
windpipe then Bobby was on his knees on
the ground clawing at his own throat as
he gasped for air a thin line of blood
trickled down his neck there's something
invisible small and sharp had cut into
his skin then rushed to the side of his
Fallen Brethren picking them up in his
massive arms and pulling them back out
of the way I guess if you want something
done right you gotta do it yourself
Mario said pulling his favorite pistol
out of his pocket and aiming it directly
between the stranger's eyes please you
don't want to do this The Stranger
begged but Mario wouldn't yield oh I
very much do call it a belated birthday
present and he pulled the trigger when
the police arrived to investigate the
sound of gunshots they found a bizarre
our Sight Four gangsters lying dead on
the ground from a gunshot wound choking
stabbing and a heavy Blow To The Head at
the center of it all there was one man
completely unharmed except for a hole in
his shirt and some dirt on his suit
unsure what else to do with the
situation they arrested the man and
brought him in for questioning the
murder suspect had no identification on
him and refused to give the officers a
full name so they threw him in a holding
cell and designated him a John Doe they
questioned the man for hours trying to
get him to explain how he had taken down
four of the city's deadliest gangsters
without getting a scratch on him or
where he had managed to stash his
weapons before the police got there
every time he insisted I never touched
them at the same time the SCP Foundation
was combing their way through arrest
records looking for any signs of the
strange and unusual passing through
police custody they paid particular
attention to Jon and Jane does looking
for people with superhuman abilities or
unexplained characteristics the events
in New York City caught their eye Ai and
a foundation operative was dispatched to
retrieve the strange man from the NYPD
they found him sitting in his cell
reading a newspaper refusing to answer
any more questions when the operative
noticed a large bruise on the attending
officer's face he stammered the guy
wasn't cooperating I tried to show him I
was serious but this happened he hit you
the operative asked the policeman simply
shook his head no I I don't know how he
does it I hate him the man was released
into the custody of the SCP Foundation
and officially designated
scp-073
scp-073 is a man of Middle Eastern
descent standing at six foot one inches
tall with black hair and blue eyes he
appears to be in his early 30s but
Research indicates that he is much older
than that he looks like an average man
with a few noticeable exceptions his
arms legs spinal cord and shoulder
blades have been replaced with metal of
some kind when asked about these metal
additions the subject seems surprised
and insists that he has no memory of
when when or why the alterations were
made he has a symbol carved into his
forehead which has not yet been
translated though it seems to be
Sumerian in origin the subject is aware
of the symbol's presence but does not
like to discuss it at all he becomes
distressed whenever it is brought up and
refuses to explain
scp-073 has the needs of an ordinary
human being and requires regular
consumption of meals as well as plenty
of water he subsists on a strictly
animal-based diet of various meats and
cheeses which are provided for him on
demand he refers to himself as Kane and
is generally friendly and polite to
everyone he interacts with if a bit
formal and stiff he is extremely helpful
and has volunteered to help out with
various tasks around the foundation site
from cleaning and general maintenance to
assisting in research he prefers to
provide assistance on the research side
of things largely due to his
photographic memory wide knowledge of
world history and fluency in most of the
world's common spoken languages when he
was first brought into Foundation
custody he provided evidence of these
skills via a placement test in French
German English Japanese Mandarin Italian
and a dozen other languages a trivia
contest where he bested the foundation's
top historian and a memory exam wherein
he read an entire 800-page dictionary in
a minute and a half and was able to
recite every single word without help in
addition to his intelligence and some of
the unusual aspects of his appearance
the subject also possesses some
impressive and strange abilities Kane's
physical presence is deadly to any life
grown in soil from fruits and vegetables
to trees grass and anaerobic bacteria
any soil that Kane sets foot on will
experience this effect which extends to
all land in a 20 meter radius Kane also
has a destructive impact on plant-based
material that has undergone processing
including paper and wood and on produce
that has been grown hydroponically it is
unknown why his presence has this effect
but it influences everything from his
diet to the furniture placed in his
containment chamber Kane is impervious
to physical harm which is not out of the
ordinary for an anomaly in the custody
of the SCP Foundation but the way in
which this invulnerability manifests is
particularly notable any violence that
is directed towards Kane bounces off of
him and turns back on his attacker
whatever is done to him will affect the
person attempting to hurt him this
applies whether a person means harm or
not and whether they use a weapon or
their bare hands though the harm done to
Cain does not show up as a physical
injury he does still experience the
sensation of pain and has requested that
the foundation refrain from any
especially painful tasks especially
since he has been so Cooperative with
their research
scp-073's resistance to any physical
damage has made it difficult for the
foundation to perform any in-depth
medical tests on him a few days after he
was first brought into the research
facility a team of scientists begin to
take various DNA samples at first the
process went smoothly they cut off a
small piece of Cane's hair swapped his
mouth for a saliva sample and scraped a
few dead skin cells from the surface of
his arm then with the man's permission
they decided to go a bit deeper and take
some Blood and Tissue samples this is
where the trouble began the researcher
in charge of taking the blood sample
complained of a sudden sharp pain when
she pricked Kane's arm with the needle
occurring in the small part of her own
arm nevertheless she pushed through and
took a small vial of blood however when
the blood was tested it was found to
belong to a 40 year old woman somehow
instead of drawing blood from the test
subject the needle had filled the vial
with the researcher's own blood the
research team tried again with a
different doctor administering the blood
test but the same thing happened again
and again and again each time the person
taking the blood sample somehow
extracted a small amount of their own
blood when the team attempted to take a
small tissue sample from cane cutting
off a tiny portion of skin with a couple
the same thing happened Kane's skin was
left completely unharmed and the tissue
sample wound up belonging to the doctor
who took it in the first place
eventually after a lot of trial and
failure the head researcher declared
that there would be no more medical
tests performed on scp-073 if we keep
going at this rate we're going to have
to organize a blood drive equipped when
pressed on the matter by higher-ups why
nobody asked him to take his own blood
is to this day a mystery because the
attempts to test Kane's blood and other
organic tissue have proven fruitless the
research team turned their attention to
the more inorganic parts of his body
namely the portions of unidentified
Metal located along his limbs shoulder
blades and spine after taking a closer
look at the metal one research assistant
suggested that it might be beryllium
bronze a metal that has appeared under a
variety of other anomalous circumstances
scp-073 confirmed that this metal
originated in the Middle East many many
years ago but was unable to provide an
exact date locate solution or purpose of
origin beryllium bronze has been
identified as a component in several
scps so far including scp-1216
scp-1427
scp-2481 and scp-2711 further research
into the unusual metal and its
connection to many ancient civilizations
is considered a top priority currently
Kane is kept at SCP Foundation site 17
where he is permitted to roam freely as
long as he does not leave the facility
or come into contact with any
plant-based scps or plants of any kind a
new researcher that encountered Kane in
the site asked him for his opinion on a
bouquet of flowers the researcher had
purchased for his wife before Kane could
protest the researcher had placed the
bouquet in his hands where it
immediately disintegrated much to the
distress of both men Kane apologized
profusely and told the researcher that
he would offer to pay for a new bouquet
but unfortunately he did not have any
money a memo was sent out to all site
staff later that day to remind them of
Kane's effect on plant-based life forms
due to the frequent staff turnover at
SCP Foundation sites this reminder is
issued on a regular basis in addition to
the reminder about plant life exposure
Foundation staff are routinely reminded
that they must never use any violence
against scp-073 under any circumstances
great emphasis is placed on the fact
that this rule is for their own safety
not for the safety of scp-073 though
most of the staff know by now not to
deliberately harm scp-073 in any way
accidents still happen and one careless
moment could result in unintentional
self-injury for example one day Dr Beyer
was having lunch in the cafeteria
walking to a seat with his favorite dish
a steaming hot bowl of tomato soup with
a grilled cheese sandwich on the side he
had specifically asked the kitchen staff
to make it as hot as possible so that it
would still be warm when he had finished
his sandwich and several chapters of the
book he was reading on his break as he
passed scp-073 who was enjoying a meal
of his own Dr buyer tripped and Spilled
his scalding hot soup all over the man's
back before he could react he fell to
his knees in pain as blisters and burns
erupted across his own back Kane jumped
up from the table with a surprised yell
but his skin remained unblemished Dr
Byer on the other hand had to spend the
rest of his lunch break in the medical
wing and never got to finish that soup
Kane is permitted to interact with other
scps as long as an erection between the
two is not considered dangerous for one
or more parties involved he has not
expressed much interest in other scps
with the exception of the few that are
permitted to roam the facility as they
please for example he has engaged in
some polite small talk with scp-507 and
always gives a friendly pat on the head
to scp-999 whenever he bumps into it
there is one SCP however that Kane has
specifically requested he never be in a
room with
scp-076 also known as able though he has
kept his personal knowledge of
scp-076 to himself Kane has admitted
that he knows everything about the man
he would not elaborate further and
simply said that it would be better for
everyone involved if the two never met
no one knows for certain what would
happen if those two superhumans came
face to face but if someone as powerful
as Kane is afraid of the consequences it
certainly cannot be good now go check
out scp-073 and scp-076 Kane vs Abel and
scp-6008 Noah's Ark for more epic
anomalies